c'est une petite révolution à maurepas
le magasin auchan a acheté une machine
qui permet la désinfection rapide des
cas dit elle sert à simplifier la course
pour les clients puisqu'elle permet de
pulvériser en trois secondes une
solution hydroalcoolique pour
désinfecter le chariot dans ce qui évite
aux clients de voir le faire avec du
papier sopalin et un pulvérisateur
manuel c'est vraiment un plus pour leur
faire gagner du temps la machine
fabriquée en europe a été acheté à une
entreprise locale
simple d'utilisation elle est désormais
en libre service
les premiers temps passé au côté de la
machine pour voilà expliquer aux clients
les retours sont globalement positifs on
va dire qu'il ya 99% les clients sont
rassurés et satisfait de ce nouveau
service les clients justement commence à
prendre l'habitude certains restent
méfiants quand d'autres se réjouissent
là c'est tellement rapide que je sais
pas trop où on a du mal à se rendre
compte comment tu peux te désaffectée
aussi rapidement
mais bon je me plie à ce qu'il faut
faire pour rassurer une maximum de
sécurité pour les autres et pour moi ça
va très vite
en plus c'est jeudi j'avais vu ça à la
télé
je trouve que c'est impeccable au lieu
de prendre du produit nettoyer tout ça
c'est super on dit qu'ils sont les
poignées tout ça faut faire attention
nous c'est ce qu'on fait moins chaud ça
j'ai donc oui si on fait très attention
la machine étant maintenant propriété du
magasin va rester en libre-service au
moins pour quelques mois voire plus si
besoin